[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday I'm
getting my abs in shape for my
punishment also welcome to my basement
what do you think Hank the light in the
basement isn't very good let's go
outside is it bad to my abs kind of hurt
after those four situps okay I got to
make this video super fast because I
gotta go out tonight and also I have to
get back to revising my new book by the
way Hank I have decided that my new book
is definitely going to be called Paper
Towns unless I change my mind again do
you like that title I mean I know it's
not super commercial but it is the
perfect title for the actual book it's
interesting that my puff levels
generally are not very high but then the
puff level just right here in this area
is extraordinarily high puff puff puff
Hank I do have a small piece of bad news
regarding my punishment I seem to have
thrown away all of my Academic Decathlon
medals Hank I know what you're wondering
you're wondering is that really Harry
and the Potters doing the nerdfighter
hand thing Hank it is that's some
nerdfighters with Harry and the Potters
yay Harry and the Potters they're like
the number one Harry Potter band in the
world commenter margaret said something
about how my academic decathlon medals
proved that I'm smart but I'm afraid
that's not actually the case the way
academic decathlon works is there are
three tiers of students you've got your
a students your B students and your C
students a students have GPAs of 3.75
and above B students have GPAs above 3.0
and then C students have GPAs below 2.99
basically what those medals mean is that
I was the third best C student in the
state of Alabama which is not quite the
same thing as being smart
hey Hank I'm wondering if we can add
just one more thing to the punishment
the commenters in my pants have been
crazy about the idea that we're going to
dye our hair green I think that's a
great idea except that most green hair
dyes last for about eight weeks which is
a little long if you're about to turn 30
years old I mean if I was 26 27 eight
weeks of green hair no problem but when
you're 30 just seems kind of sad
fortunately there's that awesome
spray-on green hair pictured here so
Hank here's my idea you spray paint this
part the mohawk part and then all spray
paint all of these parts the parts that
aren't Mohawk II and then between the
two of us we'll have a whole head of
green hair Hank I hope it's a nice day
in Missoula it's certainly beautiful
here in Indianapolis I'm going to go and
enjoy the day now I'll see you tomorrow